hey guys I'm Bryce and er this is
housewives happy hour and Lisa
Vanderpump is here with Giggy
I'm gonna gossip rose' a glass of rose a
cheer cos season 8 of Beverly Hills can
you believe it season 8 after the first
one I said no well I think I've done
that that's it
seven years later Here I am who you are
how do you feel about this season
in fact she could season for me there
was some stuff swirling around me but I
was ducking and diving ducking and
diving and driving away in tears ah well
yes there was that little moment oh yeah
I actually had my cool and they kind of
lost it that day but for the most part I
think you know this show is all about
it's authentic Kyle told me that don't
believe a word of it she said she cannot
see herself doing this show without you
I lovely songs were the closest of the
bunch and I couldn't never do the show
without her do you feel the same really
no not at all as soon as she's out of
there I'm like gonna be from what I do
think in some ways we're very much the
backbone of the show because whether to
existing and our friendship was always
so strong it was so authentic lots of up
and ups and downs for you guys over the
years yeah but now I feel like you're
you've found the right groove yeah no
yeah yeah but it's a 14 you'll see what
the crew that she goes get with okay
okay then forward do I don't see looking
forward to it maybe that's one you
should skip you didn't like that it
wasn't about you for a minute
cheers for that shears that to surviving
another season of housewives exactly and
if things don't get any better than I
insist you drink before I say it won't
forget
you
[Music]